For a hyperbola that is not centered at the origin, we can use h comma k as its
center. This actually gives us two equations for hyperbolas. This equation has
the x squared term coming first. So the parabola will open to the left and to
the right. H and k will be our center. And the value of a will be how many
units we move in the x directions. And the value of b will be how many units we
move in the y direction. This allows us to graph our ellipse, and then draw the
box around it for our rectangle. Other hyperbolas however open up and down.
These hyperbolas start with the y squared term. This term will be positive
instead of being negative. But notice that h and k have been switched here. H
is still with x and k is still with y. But k comes first in this equation and h
comes second. So, you want to keep this mind when finding the center if the
hyperbola opens up and down. The h value will be this value and the k value
will be this one. This might be confusing but you can always remember that
anything associated with the x direction will be with the variable. For
example, the x coordinate of the center will be h. That's with the x. And the
way we move in the x direction, a will be here. Underneath the x squared term.
Likewise, anything having to do with the y or the y direction will be next to
the y variable. The y coordinate of the center k is here, and the way we move
vertically up and down, the value of b is here. These equations aren't that
different. And really the things with a squared and b squared work exactly the
same as before. The only difference is that this hyperbola opens left and right
since the x squared comes first and this parabola opens up and down since the y
squared term comes first and is positive. The other subtle difference is hk.
Here they're in order, h and then k. Here we need to be careful and get the h
next to the x. And then get the k that's with the y.